why do people have to be all complicated
and difficult to fully flesh out okay so
the reaction to the queerbaiting video I
did a little while back was a lot bigger
than I'd anticipated and it's made me
kind of realize I think there's a little
bit of an itch to be filled and I think
by a channel that is not exclusively or
even primarily about lbgtq issues but
will still touch on them and they are
still coming from the perspective of
someone who is a member of the LGBTQ
populace so in that case that means we
are going to switch out the look so
reminder my credentials and the dog that
I have in this in this race or this
fight or however you put to particularly
use the phrase I am i have a fluctuating
fluid sense of gender hence also the
shirt after all that preamble let's
address the question that is of course
the title of this video why are LGBTQ
characters so hard to include so hard to
write so hard to just have and the thing
is you may have suspected that that
title was like being asked sarcastically
like what's so hard about it except I'm
kind of asking it sincerely because I do
think there is actually an answer for
why it's hard and why it's difficult
particularly when you compare it to any
other kind of inclusion that you want to
have of any other kind of diverse not
any other but most other kinds of
diversity I mean if you want to compare
it to say racial diversity I think it's
actually much harder to include more
LGBTQ characters in TV films comic books
etc for one very simple reason - to
paraphrase a comedian that I'm rather
fond of named / Curt we look like you
and I know that sounds really weird
coming from me when I'm presenting like
this but you saw how it looked when the
video started LGBTQ people don't look
different as a general rule so unless
you are going to be visualizing the
character and an extremely stereotypical
and most likely offensive if you choose
to go that way fashion then you can't
just look at a character and know that
they're LGBTQ so again going back to
what I said if you want more racial
diversity in a story well first of all
let me even back up further than that
including any major character that is
outside of the scope of the experience
of the writer the filmmaker whoever is
the main sort of driving force of the
story is difficult not impossible but
certainly difficult and it is also a
comfort zone as far as a lot of creators
go as a rule of thumb most people tend
to write as a default themselves and
with the majority of say Hollywood being
made up of white straight men that's
what we see the most of it's what they
understand the best is what the most
comfortable writing that's natural
that's human so even but if you want to
include say more racial diversity even
if for whatever reason it either doesn't
fit the story you're telling or you're
not comfortable writing say black
characters experience because you don't
feel like you can represent that well
you can still include a racially diverse
cast you can still include black people
in say your supporting cast by having
characters where race is not an
essential part of their characterization
or honestly even if they're just in the
background you can just put them there
now it is it nice to have more fleshed
out characters and have them be you know
more present and not just there and
that's it well yes absolutely but that's
still something if all you want to do is
just normalize the fact that not every
person in an office and a crowd in a
Starbucks whatever is white you can do
that you can just have them there and
on-site you know oh okay this is a
diverse workplace this is a diverse
community this is
this is a world that this show movie
comic book is showing me that has racial
diversity in it because I can see it you
don't know that there is sexual
orientation or gender identity
um diversity unless characters say it
and that is something that makes it
harder it makes it more difficult it
makes it more work does it make it
impossible no absolutely not but it does
mean whereas you can simply drop in say
a member of a different race or even
something like say various religions
there are a lot of easy quick visual
signifiers wearing a crucifix having a a
yarmulke God took me a second for that
um traditional Muslim dress which I
don't know proper names for so I'm not
gonna try because I don't want to screw
that up but there are there are you know
easy visual signifiers for that so
there's a lot of there and of obviously
if you want to include more women
because women are also often
underrepresented in these things it's
easy hey that's a woman I can look and I
can see that but with us somebody it has
to be made clear you can't just look and
know again unless you're dealing in a
really bad stereotype I mean I suppose
technically it will count as adding
diversity if you have characters in the
background and it's like a male
character and a really flamboyant shirt
going around like this
please don't but as well I suppose you
know that will put them there but don't
don't do that
so you you had the only way that we know
that there are LGBTQ characters the only
way that we know we're there is if
attention is drawn to it either through
dialogue or through actions of
characters and that does create a couple
of issues the first is as I said is just
flat-out more work and if it is just a
side character that is work you may not
feel is worth putting into
somebody that in terms of the overall
narrative structure isn't that important
especially if you're working on
something like a film it's gonna go
through so many draft revisions anyway
what's one of the first thing that's
going to be cut why are we pausing the
scene to point out that this character
has a boyfriend get rid of that
that's just often what happens in
writing processes so you know it's work
that you put in that it's like well why
am i bothering I do think it's work work
still worth doing but just acknowledging
that it is more work to do but then
there's also the other side of that coin
which is that unfortunately because the
only way that we can confirm our
presence in these stories in movies and
comics and TV is by pointing it out in
some fashion that regrettably feeds the
narrative of shoving diversity down
people's throats and the kinds of
audience members who go God why do they
always have to point it out why is the
gay character always have to talk about
being gay because that's the only way
you know that's the only way you know
that they're gay do you want to argue
that it's not realistic fine argue that
it's not realistic do you but for you to
say just have a gig here just don't have
them say that they're gay okay fine but
how how are we supposed to know that a
character is gay or lesbian or bi or
genderqueer or whatever it has to be
pointed out that's the only way to have
it be confirmed that was a big part of
what I ranted about and the gender and
the the queerbaiting video so that again
just makes it makes it one more reason
for writers directors whoever to not
bother because it's a lot of work and
depending on the demographics that your
finished piece of work is aimed at it
could be
possibly alienating to a portion of the
audience that you want on your side if
only for financial purposes and that
makes it to be completely pragmatic
about it not worth the bother but I did
want to like talk about this I did want
to address this because I feel like I
need to address both sides you know from
people who are kind of more or less on
my side of the whole thing going why why
are we so hard to find there is a reason
you can say it's not the best reason in
the world but there is a reason and for
people on the other side going you know
why does it have to keep being said well
this is why now can it be over said oh
yeah sure if we're talking say a TV show
as opposed to like a film if a character
gets established as gay in I don't know
say there's second appearance but then
it keeps getting reiterated as if it's
being pointed out for the first time
every time they show up but their
romantic relationship is not actually
part of the ongoing narrative
yeah that's clunky and that's
unnecessary and that's overdoing it so
yes that is possible but you have to at
least grant us the first time pointing
it out because otherwise you don't know
we're there you know what it's like when
we're when we're supposedly there and
you don't know it that's called being in
the closet and being in the closet
really freaking sucks so yeah we would
we would like to to not do that and not
have to do that like ever and I think
another byproduct of this is because you
have to put the extra attention to
highlight this like I said it makes it
awkward because what are your options
either it's a minor character which is
usually a good way to at least you know
have a base level diversity you know so
it's not just a sea of white male faces
you can just add diverse characters in
minor roles but for you to know there's
an LGBTQ character you do have to add
this extra emphasis and it's weird to do
that for what would otherwise be a minor
character the
alternative is to have one of the major
characters be LGBTQ but unfortunately
that can lead to its own issue which is
that for whatever reason it really does
seem like filmmakers writers etc don't
want to do that unless the thrust the
main thrust of the story has a
character's sexual preference or gender
identity as like the point unless it's a
god I hate that I'm about to say this
term a gay movie it's pretty atypical
for them to point out that a major
character is gay or lesbian or trans or
what-have-you and like I said I hate
even using that phrase but I know it
exists as a sentiment like I know that
you can go I was gonna say go to the
video store dated reference but I know
that you can go onto things like Netflix
or Amazon and see things categorized as
LGBT movies and that is kind of a market
which frustrates me partly because I
usually don't like the kinds of stories
those are telling because they're almost
always you know look how hard it is
being this thing or you know their their
romances which rarely hold my interest
or they're just really stereotypical and
they do well enough because there isn't
enough variety in that genre shouldn't
be a genre but it counts as a genre um
and and that's one of the things that
frustrates me is because I would love to
be able to see a reflection of myself in
a story that I actually want to see I'm
a geek I like superheroes I like Star
Wars I like sci-fi I like fantasy I
don't I don't love drama I I don't mean
like as a element of a story I mean like
the drama section of of a streaming
service the the things that get filed
under drama
they don't my interest but movies where
the main character is LGBTQ it's
basically a subset of that of the drama
category and again I think there's a
there's a number of reasons for this
there's creators who aren't comfortable
telling these stories there's the fact
that there aren't enough LGBTQ people in
the industry who are able to lend their
voice and tell these stories and more
often than not if they are going to tell
these stories the only way they're
allowed to do it is if it's the
dedicated point of the story I'm
projecting to a certainty sent obviously
I don't live in Hollywood I've never
taken a meaning with a studio executive
but I I do actually know people who work
in various aspects of the industry so I
I don't feel that the characterization
I'm about to make is hugely off the mark
but if you show up to a pitch meeting or
a script discussion with an executive
with a producer with a director even and
you go so here's this high-octane action
story and the action hero's gay that's
not what it's about but he's gay and at
some point somebody in that room is
gonna go does he have to be gay like we
don't want to make it an issue movie we
want an action movie let's drop that
let's make it clean let's make it easier
let's make it cleaner and that it's a
combination of bottom line and creator
artist comfort levels and I'm not saying
that directors writers or other creators
who aren't comfortable trying to tell
those stories should be forced to tell
them of course not if you're not
comfortable telling that story don't
tell that story but unfortunately it's
easy for us to get left behind because
you have to go out of your way to
acknowledge us you can't just drop us in
the background and have anybody actually
know we're there
that's not completely exclusive to LGBTQ
there are other sort of certain areas
that where that crosses over you know
there are there are invisible
disabilities that don't present in the
form of a wheelchair or leg braces
certainly anyone who isn't is neuro
atypical I don't want to say mental
health issues because I think I feel
like that phrase has a lot of stigma to
it but you know people who have those
sorts of issues it's hard for them to
get representation for the same reason
because you only know that a character
is like that if somebody points it out
autism another solid example so it
almost never shows up unless it unless
the entire thing is about that and it is
harder it needs to be done guys and I'm
not saying it's not gonna suck sometimes
I'm not gonna say it's not it's it's not
never gonna be clunky and I'm not saying
there aren't gonna be times where you're
just gonna be painful like oh for the
love of God stop but we need to hit a
level of normalization either behind the
scenes or with the art that's being put
out ideally both because until we either
get people in positions of being the
ones telling these stories who are
comfortable handling these characters or
we just sort of get it to the point
where audiences don't go well that was
out of place when a character goes oh
yeah you know my boyfriend a night we
had a fight but you know it'll be okay
and but it's just a it's just a minor
note it's just something said in the
scene like literally just one line to
establish that this character is gay gay
people exist
we need to it needs to be there so that
people can get over it because the fact
that some people do react to even
well-handled
instances where it is just a tossed off
line where it is done as organically as
possible and they still go through
why they gotta put that in there we need
to keep putting it in there until you
stop reacting like that until it's no
longer abnormal until it doesn't stand
out anymore it's more work it's hard
there is like I said there is a reason
that it doesn't happen all that much but
I do know there is also effort going
into it unfortunately as kind of touched
on the queer baby video it is often
cynical misguided effort but there is
effort and I've said before and I will
continue to argue I would rather have
questionable iffy this is not the best
representation than no representation
because you can take something that
isn't great and work at it and make it
better it gives you a foundation gives
you something to build off of when there
is no representation there is nothing to
build off of you simply don't exist and
when you're talking about the LGBTQ
experience being ignored and feeling and
being made to feel like you don't exist
is a major part of the issues of trying
to live your truth so I think I'll wrap
up this one on that note this is gonna
be I think a monthly feature because I
don't want this kind of topic to overrun
the channel by any means but I also I
started actually sort of sketching out
topics related all this that it that I
feel like I have something to say about
and I think monthly is a good pace for
something like this so that I can I can
talk about these things and possibly
reach an audience that isn't always
hearing these sorts of things talked
about maybe but also again like I said
not having it over on the channel it's
it's not gonna become the primary
feature me letting my hair down will
still be the exception rather than the
rule but that'll I will do it for this
one folks so whatever thoughts you have
on
keep it respectful even if you disagree
with me I am I am fine to hear you out
and leave comments in place that
disagree with me as long as you were not
using pejorative terms and issuing
personal attacks either to me or anyone
else so keep it civil
whether you agree disagree whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do there's the usual the
likes and subscribe I have a patreon
naturally links for that plus my Twitter
and uh podcast and t-shirts etc it's all
down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]